I'm feeling like that's my man dammit no
one believes in love more than you
Angela but some might say that you've
given Michael one too many chances he's
lied to you in the past and those
closest to you have flat-out told you
that he's just using you for a green
card when it comes down to it Michael
does have your back after all he did
take that snail out of your mouth while
introducing you to his mom in Nigeria
this food swap scene was so disturbing
it had a squirming in our seats Oh
Angela that's the exact opposite of a
good first impression so nervous some of
the couples who appear on 90 day fiancé
truly love each other but a lot of them
are just trying to become American
citizens they'll do just about anything
to convince their fiance's that they're
in it for the long haul but they've got
ot riyer motives plastered all over
their faces we've got 10 of the most
sketchy couples lined up for you so
don't go anywhere
season seven of 90 day fiancé has
brought us some amazing couples however
not every couple that appears on the
show is a match made in Ukraine Mike's
best friend Matt met his wife Svetlana
in Ukraine and it didn't take long for
Svetlana to tell Mike all about her
blue-eyed gorgeous friend Natalie Mike
and Natalie started texting and soon
Mike booked a ticket and went to visit
Natalie in Kiev Ukraine but the more
they got to know each other the more
they realized that they had nothing in
common but that didn't stop Mike from
proposing to Natalie during his second
trip to Ukraine viewers are more than
confused when it comes to what Natalie
wants she's a super religious person who
wants nothing more than to start a
family so much so that she divorced her
ex-husband when she found out he didn't
want to have kids when I start making a
baby right now why not
problem is Mike would rather believe in
aliens than a higher power
he's $30,000 in debt and he doesn't see
himself becoming a dad any time soon and
yet Natalie was bummed when her k1 visa
was denied things are shaky between the
couple and make matters worse natalie
revealed that she doesn't love Mike in
the most Awkward interview of all time
and
would be alive from my side to say I
love him and the award for the most
toxic couple on 90 day fiancé goes to
Darcy and Jessie this couple stole the
show in seasons 1 and 2 of the reality
TV show but their relationship was
short-lived for obvious reasons first of
all there was an age difference and no
matter how hard they tried Darcy and
Jessie could never get on the same page
if you want to make a problem we can
make a problem you know we can create
some drama right now Darcy and Jessie
met on Instagram and there was an
immediate attraction but there was
something seriously wrong with the
fitness enthusiasts from the Netherlands
Jessie constantly attacked Darcy's
personality and blew up over small
issues like overcooked steak Jessie was
rude to Darcy in front of her two young
daughters and even called the cops on
her saying that she threw a shoe at him
granted Darcy wasn't the easiest person
to deal with either but regardless it
was clear that Darcy was looking for
love and commitment
while jessie was looking for some screen
time I tried my base coat and larysa
were one of the most entertaining
couples to watch on 90 day fiancé but
for all the wrong reasons of course Colt
who lives in Las Vegas proposed to
Larissa after knowing her for just five
days he met the Brazilian in Mexico and
they got married in June of 2018 but
there was trouble in paradise from the
very beginning Colts family and friends
weren't fond of Larissa who seemed to be
using Colt for his money as well as a
green card however she was quick to
point out that Colt didn't have any
money and still lived with his mother
Larissa pushed Colt to move out of his
mother's house Larissa and I were
looking at houses she wanted a luxurious
condo fancy new furniture and an
expensive car but Larissa's jealousy and
fits of rage would prove to be most
intolerable Larissa would later reveal
to Debbie that she already had two
children of her own in Brazil this was
shocking news but it paled in comparison
to Larissa's history of domestic
violence Larissa is arrested for
domestic abuse a handful of times and
despite saying that she loved Col T with
all her heart
Colt eventually filed for divorce and
tried to cancel their Issa's green card
application cult and Larissa's marriage
was a total mess Butler
is fighting her deportation at all costs
and she believes that she deserves to
stay in America yes I'm really excited
celebrate my freedom it's surprising to
find out that Eric and Lita from season
six are still together as of early 2020
because while their relationship hasn't
always made sense Eric and Lleida first
met in Indonesia and after spending just
two days together
Eric popped the big question Eric a 40
year old single father from Wisconsin
was smitten by Lita a 29 year old single
mother from Jakarta latest k1 visa was
approved and she soon moved to Wisconsin
where she eventually married Eric but
Lleida and Eric came from very different
backgrounds
whereas latest family was super wealthy
Eric was the opposite when laid a first
stepped foot in his apartment with her
young son she couldn't believe the state
it was in
turns out Eric's 20 year old daughter
Tasha had left it's super messy leading
to a huge arguments Eric tows Lita over
his daughter choosing to kick her out to
prove to his future wife that she was
his priority this stunned viewers
everywhere but what was most shocking
was how Lleida wanted Eric to stop
paying child support
later continuously through her family's
riches in Eric's face she boasted about
her first wedding and how beautiful it
was
although Eric and Lida are still married
some viewers are certain that Lleida
used Eric to become a u.s. citizen hey
you are you subscribed to the things yet
we post weekly videos about your
favorite reality TV shows so hit
subscribe and click that doll for more
if you're watching on your phone or
tablet go into your YouTube settings and
turn on notifications this way you can
stay up to date with reality dating
shows like 90 day fiancé and The
Bachelor now let's get back to our video
anyone who watched season 2 of 90 day
fiancé will surely remember Mohamed and
Danielle because well their relationship
with icky and destined to fail Mohamed
who was from Tunisia met Danielle online
and quickly convinced her that he was
the real deal so much so that she
applied for a k1 visa and brought him
over to Ohio at the time Danielle was 41
years old
and Mohammed was 26 but the 15 year age
gap didn't seem to bother them once in
America Mohammed would find out that
Danielle was broke and fooled a fit we
lost everything he would also go on to
insult her appearance by calling her
acceptable but it was clear that
Mohammad was terrified of being intimate
with Danielle who grew more and more
clingy as Mohammed pushed away viewers
weren't surprised when Muhammad left
Danielle right after their season of 90
day fiancé wrapped up production
Mohammed moved to Miami to start his new
life leaving the already broke danielle
to pay for the divorce wedding and
immigration process all on her own
danielle desperately tried to get
mohamed deported but it was too late the
scam had already run its course and
mohammed had come out on top although
Annie and David managed to stay together
and get married after their k1 visa
expired some might say that their union
was a marriage of convenience when we
first met Annie and David in season five
of 90-day fiance
their relationship got the stink-eye
after all the couple has a 24 year age
difference at the time David was 48
years old whereas Annie was 24 david was
introduced to Annie through a mutual
friend while vacationing in Thailand and
she was looking forward to starting a
new life in America Annie was vocal
about wanting to marry someone who could
take care of her but David just wasn't
up to speed his financials were
non-existent he had a drinking problem
and he was borrowing money from his
friends to make ends meet
things got super awkward when David's
best friend Chris requested that Annie
give him daily messages as a thank-you
for letting her stay in his house it was
all just weird
Annie's main concern was that David had
no money and she wanted to make sure
that if she moved to America she would
be taken care of as of 2020 David's
managed to uphold his end of the bargain
but our living situation is very fluid
Paul and Carini first appeared in
seasons 1 and 2 of 90 day fiancé
before the 90 days Carini who is from
Brazil met Paul from Kentucky online but
the relationship was flawed from the
get-go first of all Paul refused to
learn Portuguese which made
communicating
Carini and her family super difficult
law Carini eventually picked up some
English these two just couldn't see
eye-to-eye this me and crane been apart
some big trust issues and developed in
our relationship Paul didn't trust
Kamini and accused her of cheating on
numerous occasions he found out that she
was talking to other American men too
but even then they chose to get married
so that Carini could come and live in
Kentucky with Paul things between them
got even more complicated after Karina
got pregnant and gave birth to their son
Pierre in late December of 2019 Paul
took to Instagram to reveal that Carini
had officially begun
filing for divorce in Germany on
tutorial molly met and fell in love with
police after vacationing in the
Dominican Republic
the couple was showcased in season five
of the show and the relationship was
more than a little cringy first of all
molly was a 41 year old single mother
whereas luis was a 26 year old party boy
molly and luis got engaged and married
she applied for the k1 visa and luis
quickly moved into her house Molly's
family didn't rush Louise and for good
reasons too I've got a lot of concerns
about this Molly's 17 year old daughter
would soon move out of their home
calling her mother's selfish Louise and
Molly's relationship was rocky from the
start and after six months of marriage
the couple called it quits however five
months later Luis would remarry allowing
him to hold on to his American green
card which many believed was the sole
reason he linked up with Molly in the
first place I don't want Louise to use
this for a pathway to citizenship mark
and Nicki are one of the most disturbing
couples from 90-day fiance when they
were first introduced in season three if
viewers were in a state of complete
shock and for good reason - after all
Nicki was a 19 year old girl from the
Philippines who was moving to America to
be with Mark a 58 year old man to make
matters worse Nicki was younger than all
four of marks children they're signing
to spend time and someone and it is
closer to my age mark was quick to bind
Nicki expensive gifts like a car and
would do just about anything to keep her
happy - everyone's great surprised Nicki
remains married to Mark after the show
ended the couple has kept a low profile
since filing the lawsuit against the TLC
reality dating show my future depends on
her
happiness Michael and Angela are fan
favorites for a reason they're both
unpredictable and hilarious in their own
right but tons of viewers think that
Michael will do just about anything to
become an American citizen I'll put it
on go and as long as he doesn't call
Angela his elder and doesn't infringe on
her smoking she'll give him what he
wants problem is Michael wants to have a
baby and that might just be the only
thing Angela can't offer him what if I
get an egg would you carry it and that's
a wrap before you go tell us who your
all-time favorite couple from 90 day
fiancé is in the comment section below
thanks for watching the things hit that
subscribe button and don't forget to
give this video a big thumbs up we'll
catch you next time
you